bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre à
l'occasion de la rentrée de preuve par
trois notre premier invité jean-pierre
raffarin bonsoir bonsoir michel
conseiller merci donc d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec
l' agence france presse au cours duquel
bien sûr vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions d'abord au sujet des réfugiés
la france est elle prête prête dans le
sens de capable on sait que les
capacités d'hébergement sont saturés
prête également dans le sens de disposer
deuxième question et ce sera la deuxième
partie de préfér trop avec perrine
tarneaud françois hollande peut-il
encore redresser la situation celle du
pays bien sûr qu'attend la croissance
puis la sienne également même s'il
évoque deux ils évitent d'aborder le
sujet est-ce que vous reconnaissez
toujours un avantage constitutionnel au
chef de l'état en vue de 2017 vous le
dirai tout à l'heure et puis troisième
question
marine le pen peut-elle être contrée en
2017 puisque la présidente du front
national selon vous peut gagner alors
essonne l'avertissement à votre camp
vous le dirai tout à l'heure à nadège
peljak d'abord jean pierre raffarin
l'actualité immédiate avec deux rafale
qui ont effectué ce mardi leur premier
vol de reconnaissance au-dessus de la
syrie si on se partage les avions donc
un dans le ciel de syrie sur le ciel de
tirer avec les avions de bachar el-assad
est ce qu'il faudra bien un jour reparlé
avec lui avec ce dictateur qui est
accusé de crimes contre l'humanité était
de toute façon nous avons le souhait
d'un autre régime en syrie
donc nous ne voyons pas d'avenir pour
bachar el-assad dans une scierie apaisé
et en développement reste à savoir le
moment du changement en tout état de
cause il faut engager le changement mais
je trouve utile que la france sorte de
son discours ni dèche ni vachin parce
que ce ni-ni est quelque peu stérile il
faut hiérarchiser
donc on est même très intransigeant
aujourd'hui qu'il y à une évolution du
discours présidentiel
naturellement se traduit par des
interventions en syrie par voie aérienne
que cette orientation là elle est de mon
point de vue positive
est-ce qu'il faut lever les sanctions
contre la russie pour envisager une
solution négociée en syrie je pense qu
évidemment il faut reprendre un dialogue
avec la russie sur les autres sujets que
l'ukraine
nous avons une vraie discussion
difficile parce que nous n'avons pas
accepté la situation de la crimée donc
il y à une discussion avec le format
normandie engage en ukraine elle doit
selon 6 mais on ne peut pas réduire la
relation avec la russie au seul dossier
ukrainien et il est évident que pour
régler la situation dans cette région
avec la russie mais aussi avec l'iran il
faut essayer de reconstituer une
diplomatie forte pour la paix alors on
le voit les républicains sont divisés
avec les prises de position par exemple
de bruno le maire ou encore ce matin de
xavier bertrand on écoute ce dernier ils
réclament une guerre totale contre le
groupe etat islamique en syrie il faut
qu'il aille beaucoup plus loin
je ne comprends pas pourquoi françois
hollande hésitent à temps avant que l'on
agisse dans le cadre d'une guerre totale
et globale contre d'âge
regardons les choses telles qu'elles
sont des ch est aujourd'hui notre ennemi
mortel
nous ne réussirons pas seulement avec
des vols d'observation nous ne
réussirons pas seulement avec des
frappes aériennes
il faudrait au final des ombres est allé
au sol alors est ce qu'il dit vrai
jean-pierre affaires et xavier bertand
selon vous est ce qu'on recule le moment
d'une indispensable intervention au sol
pour faire plier le groupe etat
islamique
il est clair qu'il faudra qu'une
intervention au sol pour le luth et je
dirais jusqu'à la victoire finale contre
neige mais que cette intervention au sol
ne peut pas être conduite par les
français quand xavier bertrand parle de
guerre totale il faut une diplomatie
totale et globale
c'est quand on aura une diplomatie avec
tous les partenaires de la région avec
un certain nombre de pays qui pourront
assumer le leadership que l'on pourra
avoir que l'intervention ordre leur sol
il est hors de question de
point de vue que les français puissent
prendre le leadership d'une intervention
au sol
aujourd'hui quand on regarde
l'aghanistan quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé en irak
on voit bien que c'est la guerre qui
nourrit le terrorisme et c'est que c'est
parce qu'il y à eut guère je crois que
les américains sont profondément
responsables de la situation et raconte
l'histoire dont pas porter chez moi je
tombe sur
je pense qu'il faut discuter de ces
sujets mais je crois que la guerre
totale elle ne peut se faire contre
neige qu'avec une coalition
internationale plus forte et notamment
avec des partenaires de la région qui
eux peuvent s'engager sur le terrain et
au sol ce que nous ne pouvons pas faire
alors l'afflux massif de réfugiés de
syrie notamment et puis bien sûr la
photo du petit et lan ont conduit à
l'évolution de la stratégie militaire
française en gala merkel qui a montré le
chemin de l'accueil estime que
l'allemagne va être changée par ces
arrivées massives à ce que la france va
être changée également selon vous jean
pierre raffarin
je pense que ces événements sont très
importants et que tout ceci va avoir des
conséquences dans notre pays des
conséquences profondes difficile à le
changer donc je crois que cela va
changer je crois que nous allons les uns
et les autres prendre conscience de
progressivement non seulement de la
situation extrêmement dangereuse dans
laquelle nous sommes avec les menaces
terroristes aussi mais aussi les
migrations vous savez moi je n'ai pas
attendu la photo pour vous dire ici mais
c'était à la mi juin qu'il faudrait
accueillir dans les jeux vous souvenez
vous souvenez les réactions mais je peux
vous dire que les flux migratoires sont
des sujets majeurs qui sont posées au
pays donc il faut regarder la réalité en
face
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'une
politique de quotas c'est à dire une
politique de plafond est aujourd'hui
nécessaire
je trouve bien que ce serait une
politique au niveau européen on ne peut
pas avoir de politique européenne sans
savoir une répartition de l'effort c'est
à dire dès qu'on croyait des pays qui
rejette les quotas par exemple la
pologne est ce que la pologne encore sa
place dans l'union européenne
lorsqu'elle a et la hongrie qui achève
la construction de 2 de sa barrière le
long de sa frontière avec la serbie
peut-elle rester dans l'union la
construction européenne est une affaire
difficile on a choisi
des principes comme celui de l'unanimité
et donc si à chaque fois qu'on a des
accords aux mets dehors on risque de
casser le processus européen très
rapidement donc il faut essayer de
convaincre qu'il faut pouvoir entraîner
de ce point de vue là il faudrait que la
france prenne des initiatives ce que je
remarque c'est que la france est à la
remorque
on est souvent à la remorque des états
unis on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur le dossier
syrien ont été allègrement sur les
quotas et on a été à la remorque
d'angela merkel d'abord sur la rigueur
quand il s'agissait du débat sur la
grèce c'est madame merkel qui est apparu
comme celle qui était la meilleure pour
défendre les intérêts des européens face
aux dépenses inconsidérées et on a vu
que sur la générosité après avoir gagné
sur la rigueur c'est encore madame
merkel qui prend le leadership
donc je pense aujourd'hui que la france
est en train d'être menacé de
déclassement que nous glissons vers un
statut de puissance de deuxième rang et
ça c'est extrêmement grave
de ce point de vue là et la personne
migrants personne ne peut se réjouir de
la faiblesse actuelle du président
français et en quoi le pays peut être
changée par l'arrivée massive de
réfugiés
précisément selon parce que c'est une
affaire culturelle est une affaire
difficile et ça vous inquiète parce que
beaucoup de responsables des
républicains disent que la
présidentielle de 2017 va se jouer sur
l'identité d'identité évoluera avec
l'arrivée de serkadji et c'est très
difficile savoir une élection
présidentielle où c'est quand on regarde
bien le passé ce qui s'est passé un an
avant l'élection présidentielle a
complètement été dépassé par l'élection
présidentielle en général le favori n en
avant n'est pas celui qui gagne donc les
fouette extrêmement prudents sur tout ça
mais il est clair que nous sommes dans
une situation aujourd'hui de gravité qui
va poser un certain nombre de problèmes
il suffit de regarder les choses en face
aujourd'hui est de voir que la
l'élection de madame le pen est quelque
chose de devenu possible regardons un
certain nombre de sondages donc la
société française qui est en crise c'est
parce que nous sommes en crise et parce
qu'il ya du chômage c'est parce qu'il ya
soixante mille saillie presque 200
faillite par jour de pme que nous sommes
dans cette situation de crispation et
que la population je la comprends peut
avoir peur d'un certain nombre de
menaces d'eau et donc et il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui on sera situation
économique meilleure
seraient en situation sociale et
politique familiale plus ouvert même
s'il ya beaucoup d'élan de générosité à
blockhauss générosité il ya la tradition
de la france mais il est clair qu'il ya
aussi beaucoup d'inquiétudes et que ceux
qui ont faim qui sont à la recherche
d'un emploi qui n'ont pas d'emploi peut
être inquiet de voir des gens arriver
pour eux aussi demander des emplois
alors françois hollande lors de sa
conférence de presse s'est montré
confiant il s'est voulu confiant tous
les cas sur l'organisation de l'accueil
a lors de sa conférence de presse on les
écoute
c'est une crise elle est dramatique
elle est grave elle peut être maîtrisée
et le sera alors est ce que vous êtes
aussi confiante le chef de l'état jean
pierre raffarin sur notre capacité
simplement à accueillir le flot de
réfugiés s'ils continuent de
s'intensifier
est ce qu'on pourra faire le tri
vraiment comment nous l'annoncent entre
les migrants économiques et les réfugiés
qui fuient les persécutions et les
horreurs de la guerre
je pense que ce sera plus difficile que
ne le dit le président de la république
il est vrai que vingt-quatre mille
migrants sur deux ans je pense que notre
pays tout à fait capable de faire cet
effort 36000 communes une organisation
nationale décentralisée on peut
atteindre les objectifs qui sont ainsi
fixés mais on voit bien que notre vrai
défi derrière ce sujet là c'est la
politique d'immigration et là on voit
bien qu'on est pas du tout prêt et qu'il
y à un certain nombre de défis à bâtir
moi personnellement je suis favorable à
une politique de quotas pour
l'immunisation une politique de quotas
je dirais à la canadienne
c'est à dire que on se donne une double
obligation accueillir mais accueillir
pour intégrer accueillir pour réussir
non pas accueillir pour mettre dans des
impasses mais pas de doute sur la
capacité aujourd'hui de la france à
intégrer ces populations venues
d'ailleurs alors qu'elle n'arrive pas à
intégrer certaines de ces populations
qui sont nés sur son sol
on ne pourra le faire que si on fait des
quotas c'est à dire d'accepter ce qu'on
peut intégrer
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
travailleurs étrangers qui viennent sur
notre territoire parce qu'il ya aussi un
certain nombre de métiers que les
français se refuse de faire il y à un
certain nombre de métiers aujourd'hui
lequel il ya de l'offre d'emploi qu'on
n'a pas de demande d'emploi donc il ya
un certain nombre de métiers sur
lesquels on peut accueillir parce que je
ne veux plus parler plus appliquée parce
que les français ne veulent plus parce
qu'on n'a pas d'attirance ou parce qu'on
n'a pas la demande qui correspond à
l'offre et donc ceci est déjà été gérée
dans un pays démocratique comme le
canada ou le canada s'engage à
accueillir ce qu'il peut intégrer
moi je crois que c'est ça le coeur d'une
politique d'immigration et c'est là où
les choses seront moins faciles pour le
président de la république parce que
définir cette politique là ce sera très
sensible dans le pays notamment doyon à
la veille d'une élection président alors
concernant les réfugiés jean pierre
raffarin ce que françois baroin appelle
les naufragés même si lui il ne veut pas
en accueillir dans sa villa 3 certains
maires républicains ne veulent prendre
que des chrétiens 1 par exemple à roanne
ou à belfort vous n'êtes pas heurter je
crois par cette idée mais on sait
d'ailleurs effectivement que c'est la
communauté chrétienne qui est menacé
d'extermination 1
mais pour le ministre de l'intérieur
c'est une idée funeste que lui
répondez-vous qui est contraire non
seulement aux grands traités
internationaux aux conventions et même à
l'esprit je viens qui vous anime
je pense que il faut veiller sur ces
sujets à respecter les positions des uns
et des autres mettons pas trop de
brutalité dans le débat on a déjà le
fonds national qui est aux aguets sur ce
débat est donc si nous ajoutons de la
violence de la brutalité aux débats on
ne conduira qu'à des crispations donc
respectons un certain nombre de
positions
il est clair que ce qu'ils disent est
clair aujourd'hui qu'il ya une priorité
oui qui nous paraît très important c'est
l'extermination des chrétiens qu'il faut
combattre
demain matin au sénat nous recevons à
8h30
laurent fabius avant le conseil des
ministres qui vient faire une
communication sur notre soutien aux
chrétiens d'orient donc qu'il y ait une
priorité chrétiens d'orient qui soit
affiché le même dirigeant sais c'est pas
quelque chose qui est scandaleux ce que
je crois c'est qu'en ce qui concerne la
politique des réfugiés
il doit y avoir une politique nationale
de ce point de vue là j'avais demandé la
nomination d'un haut responsable
national pour coordonner et pour
incarner cette politique je crois que ça
c'est utile
ça c'est une politique nationale qui ne
doit pas faire de ségrégation après
que chaque maire puisse apporter sa
sensibilité puisse apporter ses
engagements il faut loi moi je pense qu
il faut il faut pouvoir tenir compte de
ce que peut souhaiter un maire est
respectée les positionner et surtout pas
faire d'ostracisme et surtout pas aller
chercher une violence va l'oral vous
diront pas d'ostracisme envers louis
mais sélection de religion musulmane
je comprends qu'il faut être qui
accueillirent et les musulmans surtout
que très franchement les musulmans qui
font partie de ces réfugiés sont des
gens qui fuient le djihadisme qui fuit
le terrorisme et qui seront dans notre
société nos alliés contre le terrorisme
donc je suis pour l'accueillir
ce que je veux dire c'est que quand on
connaît la situation des chrétiens
je comprends qu'un chrétien puisse se
dire à un moment la priorité c'est
d'accueillir des chrétiens il y a chacun
peut avoir sa sensibilité je pense que
la politique nationale doit veiller aux
équilibres et qu'on accueille tout le
monde mais qu'on ne se lance pas au
visage des anathèmes pour laisser penser
que notre pays serait divisé entre des
bons et des mauvais sur cette cause là
je demande aux mises l'intérieur comme
aux autres de bien vouloir chercher à
rassembler les français plutôt qu'elle
est divisée
laissons à madame le pen le soin de la
division et nous jouerons la carte du
rassemblement
deuxième partie de preuves par 3 tout de
suite et cette question françois
hollande peut-il encore redresser la
situation
père internautes public sénat arrive les
réformes économiques et sociales n'était
pas au coeur de la sixième conférence de
presse de françois hollande où la vie
noté il se centrer sur les questions
régaliennes même s'il se présente en
président qui fait des choix sans répit
en attend notamment une réforme du droit
du travail mais écoutez le ministre des
finances michel sapin qui estime lui que
la france va mieux
la france va mieux elle va mieux
est-ce qu'elle va suffisamment mieux non
donc il s'agit pas de dire je suis
satisfait de ce qui se passe nous allons
avoir une croissance moyenne sur
l'ensemble de l'année de 1% ou un peu au
delà
mais notre objectif c'est qu'à la fin de
cette année nous soyons sur un rythme de
croissance sur une capacité de
croissance supérieure à 1% qui est
voisine de 1 25% parce que c'est autour
de cette croissance la croissance et
l'activité dans les entreprises des
commerces
les artisanales et services que l'on
peut créer suffisamment d'emplois pour
faire reculer durablement le chômage
voilà le constat optimiste de michel
sapin bonsoir perrine tarneaud vos
questions à jean pierre raffarin
bonsoir jean pierre enfin est ce que
vous vous soulager l'optimisme du
gouvernement en matière économique
évidemment non la réalité économique je
vous dis c'est 200 faillite par jour
aujourd'hui en france on peut pas
partager cette au pied et surtout ce
discours général sur la croissance alors
qu'il faut parler de chiffre d'affaires
qu'il faut parler de développement de
marchés nouveaux d'innovation qui vous
parlez de choses très concrètes et pas
discours de la croissance comme si la
croissance était miraculeuse et surtout
qu'elle serait faite par l'état ce qui
me paraît aujourd'hui évident vous
disiez monsieur ressort que la politique
économique n'avait pas été au coeur de
la conférence de presse ce qu'on peut
regretter c'est que l'activité
économique n'est pas au coeur de ce
quinquennat
depuis le début le président de la
république il pas beaucoup pas beaucoup
et vraiment pas beaucoup il n'y a que
ceux cette aide à l'innovation avec le
crédit d'impôt dont on peut dire qu'il
peut apporter un certain nombre de
satisfactions mais que globalement il
est très inefficace il est très lourd et
que pour l'argent dépensé on aurait pu
faire beaucoup de bébés chats
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y à vraiment
des efforts à faire pour les entreprises
moi je pense qu'il ya une priorité des
priorités c'est d'alléger l'impôt des
entreprises pour les résultats
réinvestis à partir du moment où une
entreprise réinvestit ses résultats il
faut un fort allégement fiscal il faut
une politique de l'offre
le président de la république annoncé il
y a un an maintenant pour ses voeux
qu'il fallait une politique de l'offre
aujourd'hui il nous parle d'une
politique ministérielle de m pour les
ménages est vrai qu'aujourd'hui mois
pour les entreprises pour cette rentrée
pour cette rentrée les annonces
concrètes elles concernent surtout et
bien les revenus des ménages avec une
baisse de 2 milliards d'impôts annoncées
ils tirent ainsi françois hollande
finalement les leçons du ras-le-bol
fiscal oui mais d'une manière j'ai
regardé il nous dit une politique pour
les entreprises et maintenant il dit une
politique pour les ménages c'est une
politique qui à un moment va dans un
sens et qui dans l'autre moment
c'est une politique qui hésite c'est une
politique qui tortille c'est une
politique qui n'est pas clair il n'y a
pas de vision
il n'y a pas de perspective il n'y a pas
d'ambition économie aujourd'hui il faut
aider les entreprises à créer des
emplois
nous avons une situation quand on
compare à l'allemagne qui n'est pas
satisfaisante quand on regarde le coût
horaire du travail quand on regarde le
poids des charges
quand on regarde les efforts en termes
d'innovation nous pouvons faire beaucoup
mieux
et pour cela il faut mobiliser sur les
entreprises c'est ce que ne fait pas le
gouvernement et à nouveau on joue la
carte électorale en dix ans on a
augmenté les impôts de très fortement et
maintenant on va les baisser on va aller
baissé beaucoup moins que les auparavant
augmenté tout ceci est un discours
politique
je peux reprocher au chef de l'état
d'anticiper sa campagne électorale
la situation est trop grave aujourd'hui
pour avoir des mesures électoral plutôt
que de penser à la politique il faut
penser à la france et il ans quand même
certaines réformes encore des chantiers
comme par exemple le droit du travail
françois hollande le gouvernement qui
devrait s'inspirer donc du rapport
combrexelle qui va être rendu demain et
qui promeut finalement la supériorité la
forte des accords collectifs sur la loi
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
évolution que beaucoup à droite appelé
mais bien sûr qu'on est d'accord mais on
voit bien que dans les discours et dans
les interviews on revient un petit peu
en disant on ne remettra pas en cause
les 35 heures on ne remettra pas en
cause telle ou telle disposition par
exemple on n'a pas voulu remettre en
cause les seuils le sujet de l'article
vous allez encore sur le sec par exemple
que tu dois reste un tabou
le salaire minimum ou pas le souhait que
ça peut se discuter mais moi je suis
plutôt favorable au smic je l'aï alors
fortement augmenté
et quand j'étais premier ministre pour
moi je comprend enfin que je comprends
la discussion par exemple sur les seuils
sur les seuls à ces vos grands combats
sur les joues ça a été voté par le sénat
et quand vous dites que la droite sur
les 35 heures on a quand même fait la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires et ça c'était vraiment
pour les travailleurs sur lesquels
france de poids mais oui mes regrets sur
la tva sociale rocade
on voit bien qu'il est hésitant il finit
par avoir comme promesse leur gré
on n'est pas élu avec le regret comme
promesse donc il faut il et je trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation faible et
je ne m'en réjouis je pense que
aujourd'hui la faiblesse du président
est un vrai sujet je me souviens de 2002
quand le candidat socialiste n'a pas pu
être qualifié pour le second tour
je vois des sondages aujourd'hui qui
montre que le président la république ne
serait pas qualifié au second tour
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on à
madame marine le pen au second tour
potentiellement ça veut dire que la
faiblesse du président de la république
aujourd'hui sa faiblesse dont il est
responsable peut nous conduire à voir
une madame le pen au second tour et dans
un contexte d'une guerre dans un
contexte où nous devons accueillir des
réfugiés dans un contexte difficile
l'éventualité de la victoire de madame
le pen peut-être pour la première fois
dans notre histoire récente
peut-être une victoire pour elle est
donc une grande défaite pour la france
et donc voilà la grande question qui est
posée
voilà le résultat dacca qu'elle ait un
socialiste de peu à la fin j'ai
peut-être aujourd'hui républicains aussi
de votre corps moi je vous prie fait le
pari que nous serons ce contour est
d'ailleurs dans les législatives qui ont
eu lieu en général les républicains sont
au second tour donc la menace
aujourd'hui de l'absence qui risque
d'être doublé par le front national
quand vous regardez aujourd'hui la
situation c'est l'échec des socialistes
qui conduit le madame le pen est au
second tour comme c'était le cas en 2002
votre réaction à une annonce ségolène
royal aujourd'hui jean pierre raffarin
fessenheim qui ne fermera pas avant la
fin du quinquennat mais sans doute en
2018 quand le père de flamands qui
rentrera en fonction
vous dites quoi ce soir encore une
promesse non tenue du candidat françois
hollande ou alors le gouvernement fait
finalement preuve de réalisme
encore une promesse non tenue et je me
réjouis que cette promesse ne soient pas
tenues car dans les promesses de
monsieur hollande il y avait beaucoup de
promesses inacceptable des promesses que
nous avons combattu dont celle là est en
jeu la matière est programmée pour le 8
oui mais ça nous reverrons ça parce
qu'en 2017 nous rediscuterons tous ces
sujets et candidat présidentiel pour en
débattre
donc à partir du moment où le président
de la république renvoie 2018
je le trouve bien confiant sur l'avenir
du socialisme en france
en tous les cas là françois hollande a
annoncé sa volonté de mener
boudeuse réforme constitutionnelle ce
qui suppose la convocation du congrès
ont les côtés vos réagissez je suis
effectivement favorables à ce que de
réforme constitutionnel puisse être
votée ce qui suppose des majorités l'âge
la première réforme sur les langues
régionales c'est un texte qui depuis 20
ans n'a pas été encore ratifié parce
qu'il n'a pas été regardée comme pouvant
être conforme à la constitution
donc je veux tenir la parole de la
france qui a été exprimée il ya déjà
plus de 20 ans et deuxième sujet de
conseils de super de la magistrature oui
je pense que d'ailleurs dans l'intérêt
du pays tout entier de ce qu'on pense
être la garantie d'une justice
indépendante
il est tout à fait nécessaire d'avoir
cette évolution et je ne comprendrais
pas d'ailleurs qu'elles ne soient pas
partagées par tous est ce que vous
partagez jean pierre raffarin cette
préoccupation de rendre la justice plus
indépendante
je croyais crypte soutenir le
gouvernement je croyais que la priorité
du gouvernement c'est l emploi et la
jeunesse le président nous avait dit
emploi jeunesse mes priorités et je vois
que rien n'est fait de sérieux sur
l'emploi et je bois pas nouveau on va
nous sortir des sujets dans les langues
régionales
à quelques semaines des élections
régionales la ficelle est un peu grosse
je crois vraiment que la vente de l'air
à l'air du temps
l'air du temps franchement est
aujourd'hui à autre chose qu'à la
politique électorale nous sommes dans
une situation de grande gravité
on attend autre chose du pays quand vous
voyez qu'on est dans la majorité de 3 7
et 3 m je ne ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui
les conditions ne sont pas réunies pour
qu'on fasse un travail institutionnel
ensemble nous voulons vraiment que des
sites la situation économique de notre
pays soit affrontés avec des mesures de
au moins sur le code du travail
puisqu'on nous annonce d'avant qu'on
aille loin j'ai vu que la cfdt avancé d
une attitude plutôt positif
alors qu'on annonce loin micron a
jusqu'à la remise en cause par le
contrat d'entreprise d'un certain nombre
de règles nationales
s'il ya cette réforme là oui on peut on
peut avoir un débat institutionnel avec
par exemple auriez-vous
cité comme qu'il faudrait remettre en
cause je pense que la durée de manière
du travail
d'accord j'ai pu et je lui ai dit non tu
ne lances dit non et rendre les seuils
ont délivré une évolution
et puis d'autres parents ont dit non
donc je ne crois pas à tout ça les six
passionnés pourquoi réparé un deuxième
projet de loi un macron 2 pour
libéraliser de nouveaux pans de
l'économie
un texte sans doute pas par la voie
législative par ordonnance par décret
pour aller vite vous semble la bonne
voie le président république encore dit
hier qu'il voulait accélérer la
procédure
car si c'est pour aller vite sur des
petites choses pourquoi pas moi je pense
que monsieur macron a des qualités
je pense que notamment sur ce qui est en
train de se passer dans la société
française c'est à dire notre
digitalisation de l'économie cette
économie digital qui devient
envahissante je pense que il ya beaucoup
de sujets qui sont importants y compris
pour créer des emplois
donc si le miz l'économie va avancer
vite sur ce sujet moi je ne suis pas
hostile à la procédure des ordonnances
je ne suis pas hostile à ce qu'on gagne
du temps tout le problème c'est de faire
des choses utiles et parfaire des
gadgets ou des opérations qui visent à
avoir une sensibilité de circonstance
faire un congrès sur les langues
régionales dans la perspective des
élections régionales s'est pas
fondamentalement ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui il ya des manifestations de
buralistes aujourd'hui le sénat est
plutôt de leur côté puisque comme les
buralistes il refuse la neutralité du
paquet de cigarettes
pourquoi ce n'est pas une mesure de
santé publique selon vous non nous
pensons qu'aller improvisé qu'elle n'est
pas vraiment sérieuses aujourd'hui et
donc les buralistes nous paraissent
responsable et il faut les écouter
je crois que là encore à partir du
moment où on est attaché à la vie
sociale au commerce de proximité de la
ville public et de la santé oui mais
même dans la santé publique
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses pour lutter
contre le tabac mais ce n'est
certainement pas avec des opérations de
cette nature qui sont des opérations au
fond de communication mais qu'ils
n'atteignent pas cet effort quelques
pays c'était rien n'est vraiment prouver
et je crois que sur ce sujet on est
encore là dans le
le glas cosmétiques ont fait semblant de
faire et on va continuer à faire
semblant de réformer à faire semblant
d'agir
alors qu'on attend des choses concrètes
pour la vie quotidien des fonds aux
élites ce soir que la majorité du sénat
restera derrière les murs alice nous
entendre la ministre du genre discret le
temps mort noyé dans toutes les réunions
que nous avons eues aujourd'hui je ne
vois pas se dessiner et un soutien au
gouvernement sur ce sujet vous ne
craignez pas les critiques justement
alors que je le rappelle c'est un sujet
de santé publique majeur avec le nombre
de victimes dues au tabagisme chaque
année écoutez il ya le nombre de fumeurs
qui ne diminuent pas vraiment dans notre
pays contrairement à d'autres aux états
unis je pense que sur ce sujet il n'y a
pas de majorité favorable au sénat pour
finir françois hollande a réitéré hier
son engagement à ne pas se représenter
si le chômage ne baisse pas c'est une
évidence moral selon lui mais il n'a pas
précisé mais la durée de cette baisse ni
son amplitude à votre avis à partir de
combien de mois de baisse de chômage
françois hollande pour être représenté
je pense que c'est aux français
d'apprécier c'est aux français de ne
pouvoir dire s'ils sont satisfaits de sa
propre politique à ce que je voie
d'expression de l'opinion que ce soit
dans les élections municipales dans les
élections départementales et demain dans
les élections régionales
je ne vois pas une satisfaction
populaire s'exprimer pour le
gouvernement
donc vous savez quand on regarde bien
les choses les élections départementales
ont été une catastrophe pour les
socialistes a vraiment été un rejet
national très important donc aujourd'hui
je pense que ce qu'on attend du
président de la république c'est qu'ils
changent de rythme qui change de
dimension et qu'il s'attaque vraiment à
sa priorité c'est à dire l'emploi et la
jeunesse de ce pays mais s'il se
présente en 2017 est ce que vous le
verrez comme un adversaire il est si
diminué à vous écouter jean pierre
raffarin
mais de toute façon un président de la
république a une place institutionnelle
forte dans notre pays cependant
aujourd'hui dans un certain nombre de
deux sondages
il n'est pas au second tour on a vu une
position institutionnelle forte avec
monsieur jospin en 2002 qui était
premier ministre qui n'a pas été au
second tour
on a aujourd'hui un front national très
élevé regardez les sandales
moi je pronostique dans ses trente et
une montée forte du front national
nos débats politiques actuels favorisent
d'une certaine manière un discours de je
dirais de brutalité de tensions dans la
société française alors qu'il faudrait
faire de la pédagogie alors qu'il
faudrait essayer de rassembler on entend
plutôt du discours de clivage est
souvent des anathèmes qui oppose les
français donc il ya un risque front
national pour ça le président de la
république aujourd'hui me paraît le
premier menacé donc c'est probablement à
lui de faire le plus d'efforts pour
développer une pédagogie national du
rassemblement
merci perrine troisième partie
maintenant de preuves par 3 avec nadège
peljak notre consoeur de la fp qui
arrive et puis cette question donc
marine le pen peut-elle être contrée en
2017 vous avez maintenant de sérieux
doutes on l'entend alors est ce un
avertissement à votre camp vous allez
pouvoir nous le dira
alors que l'on a vu bien les principaux
responsables des républicains se
retrouver les principaux rivaux j'ai
envie de dire pour 2017 se retrouver
pour la photo de famille c'était samedi
une mise en scène bien orchestré clic
clac on le voit 8 minutes et le petit
groupe autour du sénateur bruno
retailleau hôtes des lieux s'est
dispersé on voit là on va avoir la photo
voilà
bhp jac bonsoir bonsoir photo là c'est
au village il manquait rien votre avis
elle est très belle elle n'y a pas de
femme elle est oui nathalie kosciusko
morizet elle est pas là on met les
traits de présenter mais écoutez nous
avons trois candidats qui sont mètres
d'elle mais elle n'est pas assez
féminine mais ce pas du tout elle
n'était pas loin moi je les ai vus sur
certaines photos allaient là vous les
prenez deux bouts mais quand ils sont
assis elle est là donc c'est une
présentation pour vous rattraper bien
allez on va parler d'autre chose mais
enfin doute chose si on veut pas ce que
vous dites que vous êtes unis on a bien
vu que sur cette photo bon voila c'était
la photo dr des retrouvailles en fin de
l'unité du parti
ça a duré quelques minutes vous êtes
vraiment unis parce que trop longtemps
dossier là tous les candidats les futurs
candidats à la primaire chacun pour
leurs propositions dans leur coin et où
l'unité chez vous écoutez si vous
regardez juppé sarkozy duflot valls
marine le pen et jean marie le pen de
tous ces couples l'ins encore le nôtre
qui le plus solide parce que quand on se
compare on peut toujours souhaiter que
ça aille mieux ça me fait quand on
regarde la guerre familiale au front
national
et quand on regarde la guerre
idéologique au ps au moins les nôtres
jeudi cette année au logist mais nous
nous avons des nuances de tempérament
tempérament ciel alors présentement des
tempéraments pardon à prendre puisque on
a parlé un de de la l'opération au sol
qui pourrait se faire en syrie contre
des ch
là vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
sur la même nous n'êtes pas sur la même
ligne on à monsieur bertrand xavier
bertrand et puis à bruno le maire par
exemple qui eux sont pour l'intervention
de troupes françaises les autres dit non
non non on peut envoyer des experts
c'est le point de vue de sarkozy
puisqu'il a parlé nicolas sarkozy
d'experts de françois fillon juppé lui
veut absolument pas de troupes au sol
alors voilà ça fait un sujet de
désaccord un autre sujet sur lequel vous
n'êtes pas d'accord c'est les réfugiés
ce que vous êtes vraiment d'accord parce
que y'en a qui guideront n'est pour les
quotas d'autres monnaies pas pour les
quotas il faudra en accueillir tous
où et puis les mettre dans les villages
comme vous dites et puis d'autres pièces
va écouter oui on veut bien qu'il soit
chrétien pas vraiment musulmans j'ai
bien compris ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure
enfin bon le résultat est franchement
pas la donne sur la même longueur d'onde
poussiéreux croyait que tous les
français sont sur la même longueur
d'onde mais non mais dans la société
agit des règlements de la société
française en dehors des journalistes
donnez moi quelle communauté humaine est
vraiment d'accord surtout s'il ya de
jeunes et les journalistes on est
d'accord sur tout mais globalement il ya
globalement souvent lu au total
quand vous écoutez les français
aujourd'hui le débat est complètement
ouvert dans notre pays nous ne sommes
pas à la veille d'une élection
donc on a des événements qui se présente
on parle avec notre expérience on va
discuter tout ça on va faire un projet
offrant les arbitral pour le moment on
n'est pas dans une position figée il
s'agit pas d'être en ligne indienne tous
caporaliser derrière de ses divisions
ses divisions que l'on ne procède pas
justement de la question qui nous occupe
là est ce que marine le pen peut être
contré sachant que certains responsables
de votre mouvement ce qui se présente
par exemple dans la région paca ou dans
le nord picardie doivent faire face à la
poussée du front national
je pense que la question du front
national d'abord nous rassemble elle
nous rassemble parce que nous ne voulons
pas traiter avec lui c'est notre
adversaire prioritaire nos clients
stratégiques et très clair mais sur les
sujets comme l'intervention au sol ce
sont des sujets extrêmement complexe
je comprends que avec xavier bertrand
puisse avoir des discussions
nous aurons les débats sur ce sujet et
nous les arbitreront nous décidons on
n'a pas tous les mêmes expériences
moi j'ai eu des interventions à conduire
dans un certain nombre de citations
j'étais avec jacques chirac quand nous
avons refusé d'intervenir au sol en irak
je sais pourquoi j'ai étudié cette
question j'ai regardé un savoureux
ma conviction est profonde je respecte
celle de xavier bertrand
nous en parlerons donc il est quand même
normal que dans un pays en crise quand
un certain nombre de sujets arrivent et
puisse y avoir des discussions mais pour
ce qui est des élections présidentielles
nous arbitrerons le moment venu et donc
je suis plutôt satisfait
voir que cette rentrée se fait plutôt
sur le terrain programmatique plutôt que
sur le terrain des personnes alain juppé
a sorti un livre sur l'éducation avec
des réformes très intéressantes sur
l'école primaire par exemple réforme que
j'approuve je vois que françois fillon à
une logique de rupture qui est proposée
qui est très intéressante aussi dont
nous allons pouvoir discuter je vois que
nicolas sarkozy se prépare à faire lui
aussi un certain nombre de propositions
je pense que c'est le moment pendant
sept années 2016 qui s'annonce de faire
un certain nombre de propositions nous
arbitrerons ça tous ensemble et ensuite
on choisira le meilleur pour porter à
lorsque vous disiez sur le front
national vous êtes une est en tous les
cas pour contrer le front national alors
la station dans un cas de figure
imaginons que le front national soit au
deuxième tour puisque vous avez dit
c'est tout à tout à fait possible que ce
soit original où elles avaient ou à la
présidentielle est ce qu'il faut le
front républicain contre le front
national
est ce que les socialistes doivent dire
avec la droite non se désistait les uns
pour les autres
ce que jusqu'ici vous n'avez pas voulu
puisque vous en était au ni ni à la
dernière fois nous en avions parlé c'est
la plaie toujours les hisser la position
de l'ump devenu les républicains c'est
pas d'accord avec le front national pas
d'accord très claire la position de la
famille politique on peut changer on
peut discuter mais la position de la
famille politique aujourd'hui s'il y
avait des élections demain sur ce sujet
c'est ni ni ni front national ni partie
sociale ne voulons pas être complices
des échecs du parti socialiste et nous
n'avons rien en commun avec le front
national dans cette ligne là du déni et
celle du parti
chacun peut avoir sa position je vous
donne la ligne de la famille comment
contrer le front national c'est la
question aux régionales et à la prison
je pense que ça va être un sujet très
important qui doit nous mobiliser tous
de ce point de vue là j'attends du
gouvernement qu'il fasse aussi son
travail sur ce sujet et donc nous devons
faire le nôtre sur ce sujet nous avons
deux grands sujets je pense d'une pin
tout ce qui touche à la politique
économique au projet économique qui est
un projet vraiment de chômage que le
projet du front national
sortie de l'euro c'est un projet de
chômage c'est un projet vraiment
d'aggravation de la situation
nous sommes déjà dans une situation
extrêmement difficile
les socialistes nous ont fait glisser le
front national peut nous faire
dégringoler
donc ça nous avons une ligne directrice
a mené qu'il ya une menace énorme avec
un front national qui a un programme
inacceptable pour les français dans leur
ensemble et puis ensuite on à la manière
de d'avoir une vision de la société qui
est opposée entre nous républicains et
le front national le front national
envisage toujours une forme d'ostracisme
envisage toujours une mobilisation des
uns contre les autres envisagent
toujours la différence entre les bons et
les mauvais c'est à dire la victoire
d'un camp sur un autre alors que nous
pensons que moi je pense qu'il faut
gouverner ce pays
en rassemblant et donc il y à une
logique est une logique de tension et de
l'autre côté une logique de rassembler
comment vous expliquez que cette logique
de tension et fonctionne vous le dites
vous-même mais soigné parce que mais
parce que parce que dans la société ce
sont des courants réel est ce que vous
êtes allé déjà un match de foot
est-ce que vous avez vu les tensions
qu'il est un peu qui peut y avoir dans
un entre supporters vous avez bien que
la détention ça peut exister
donc on voit on voit bien que dans la
société et quand on part on appelle les
tensions on les retrouve quand on les
appelle les tensions elle existe c'est
tout le talent d'une paix pourquoi on a
inventé la politique c'est pour éviter
la jungle pour éviter la violence
qu'est ce que la politique la politique
c'est de construire des règles pour
éviter que les gens se battent entre eux
que ce soit la loi de la jungle c'est
toi le plus fort qui écrase le plus
faible la politique c'est le vivre
ensemble
donc il y à là je crois une dès que vous
êtes engagés dans une vision
républicaine de la politique c'est de
chercher à rassembler les eaux et c'est
certainement pas de désigner en
permanence le pen n'a pas cette vision
républicaine pour rendre votre mot je
pense qu'elle n'a pas la vision du
rassemblement du pays et cette idée de
rassemblement du pays
c'est une idée fondamentalement
république est ce que c'est parce que
nicolas sarkozy lui a cette idée de
rassemblement qu'il a demandé l'autre
jour sur sa page facebook à toutes ses
troupes de mettre leurs ambitions dans
la poche pour l'instant on parle pas de
la primaire on ne parle que des
régionales il a eu raison
ce rappel à l'ordre je crois que les
élections régionales vont en effet
dominé les prochains mois et que les
électeurs des élections régionales les
militants seraient assez agacé de voir
que pendant qu'on se base sur le terrain
comme une commune par commune
département par département région par
région
à paris les leaders se bagarre entre eux
donc je crois que la priorité quand on a
les élections c'est de mobiliser les
forces sur les élections et j'espère
bien qu'on va avoir de belles élection
j'entends dire dans les sondages qu'on
pourrait gagner languedoc-roussillon
midi-pyrénées je crois que je voulais
vous dire que s'il était sur l'aquitaine
car leur jeu moi je crois que virginie
calmels en aquitaine a des chances
réelles elle était une jeune femme qui
est en train de faire une campagne très
brillant qui m'a fallu me
supplémentaires pour alain juppé on le
sait qu'il la suit la courbe de ses yeux
n'est ce pas absolument
manifestement nicolas sarkozy n'est que
le mot unité à la bouche écouté il se
présentait toujours à la baule comme
l'artisan du nitc même dit il la raison
de son retour
je suis revenu pour rassembler la
famille nous avons gagné les
départementales pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la vème république
une famille politique contrôler les deux
tiers des départements 92 % des
candidats candidature unique droite
républicaine chante
est ce que vous croyez que je suis un
homme à vous dire formidable on a gagné
en étant unis eh bien on va perdre les
régionales en étant divisés j'ai voulu
lui l'idée 17 régions 17 listes communes
républicains centristes maubeuge alors
républicains centristes
tout va bien entre vous et les
centristes moi j'ai un petit peu avancé
pour la primaire vous les clefs sans
tige les centristes en soi bien sûr je
pense qu'il faut il faut un candidat
centriste à la sas est aux centristes de
dire s'ils veulent ce que je crois c'est
que les électeurs centristes le ceux qui
ont des convictions centristes ceux qui
veulent participer aux débats politiques
doivent participer à la primaire doit
voter s'il doit y avoir un candidat
pourquoi pas moi france
pourquoi les primaires je peux m'y
intéresser je suis pas un fanatique de
l'élection avant l'élection c'est pas
parce que les socialistes l'ont fait que
ça nous convainc qu'il faut le faire
simplement je sais qu'on a un front
national qui va être très haut et que je
ne veux pas que mon candidat soit exclu
du second tour comme lionel jospin l'a
été en 2002 et comme françois hollande
peut l'être selon les sondages
aujourd'hui donc comment faire en sorte
ce qu'on ne soit pas exclue on peut être
dans le deuxième tour si on est
rassemblé pour cela il faut choisir
notre candidat avant la primaire c'est
une présélection donc à ce moment-là on
dégagera celui qui est le mieux placé
mais là où je vous rejoins il faut
vraiment que ce soit une primaire
d'unités car s'il devait y avoir une
primaire qui ne serait pas équitable
il est clair qu'à ce moment là le
processus exploserait et qu'il y aurait
des candidatures au premier temps la gpa
déjà prévus or voilà donc c'est ce que
nous devons éviter c'est pour ça que
nous sommes condamnés à des primaires
équitable est condamné à l'unité
l'instant la vie dit que c'est bien
parti mais écoute c'est un combat
difficile unité s'est dit dit ah bon
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
très important c'est qu'au fond sur le
programme
on est en voie de se rapprocher alors il
y à des tempéraments qui sont très
différents il ya des volontés politiques
des formes de gouvernance qui sont
différentes entre les différents
candidats y compris avec la jeune
génération qui peut participer à cette
présélection je pense que avec un projet
on a des chances de pouvoir convaincre
les français à deux conditions 1 que
notre projet soit vraiment un projet de
changement pour la france mais deux
qu'on montre comment en six mois on met
en place les réformes essentielles
ordonnance ordonnant ce référendum
session extraordinaire pendant tout
l'été un certain nombre de dispositifs
pour crédibiliser notre capacité à faire
puisqu'on a bien vu dans le passé que
les français avaient été déçus par les
programmes politiques parce que les
programmes politiques n'ont pas été
accompli comme les français annonce la
douleur avant et on annoncera dimon a
nnonce on annonce y compris de manière
quasi finalisées
vous voterez dans un référendum à tel
moment on fera des ordonnances sur tel
sujet et le tout dans un paquet
électoral où les français trouveront
vraiment dans les six à douze mois après
l'élection ce qu'ils ont ce pourquoi ils
ont voté vous soutiendrez qui cela je
vous le dirai au début d'un art au
printemps la passion l'a jamais la jupe
est plus que jamais et votre champion
jean pierre raffarin peut-être parce
qu'il ne s'est jamais aventuré sur les
terres ontolica sur les thèmes du front
national gd proximité avec alain juppé
il est clair que j'ai été un ministre
heureux d'alain juppé j'ai travaillé
avec lui j'étais son ministre il a été
le président ump pendant que j'étais
premier ministre
il est maire de la capitale régionale de
ma nouvelle région
donc nous avons certes des points